allez juste un doigt fois de vignerons
une saint vincent tournante ça commence
comme ça au petit matin avec le
casse-croûte et le verre de blanc
on est prêts on appréhende kamel
et moi je me parler de mon talon
pas partir à l'est mais mme brunel
sûr qu'après c'est plus facile de
défiler dans les rues du village
le saint patron bien calés sur les
épaules la bannière flottant au vent
chaque année les 77 société de vignerons
de bourgogne se réunissent autour de
saint vincent des sociétés créées au
siècle dernier
véritable caisse de secours mutuel basé
sur la solidarité
le but c'est de venir en aide à un
viticulteur lorsqu'il trouve dans la
capacité de faire son travail au cours
de l'année soit par accident soit par
maladie vous comment vous met en oeuvre
on vient en aide par le travail manuel
ou avec les facteurs maintenant on vient
de partout pour assister à la saint
vincent
mais pas seulement pour la fête des
sociétés pourquoi nuage chez moi alors
que je suis à schengen
il a dit qu'il y avait des coups à boire
ici alors on est avec nous la raconte
andré on est bien même si ça se bouscule
un peu pour se faire servir la règle du
jeu est simple il suffit de tendre le
vert que vous venez d'acheter
vous prenez vos précautions à prendre
une bien sage recommandation